if a guy of a certain caliber comes to
me the first thing i'm thinking is you
want to have sex with me oh yeah no
that's why i said i wouldn't take it's
like yeah yeah
if i had a guarantee i'd be wife like
what the i would do it yeah i think i'm
even it sounds mad right but i feel like
i'll even be more careful how soon i'll
let him sleep with me because i feel
like he's only here for the sex anyway
no that's that's um that's called alpha
widow like like have you heard the term
alpha widow an alpha widow basically
like
have you ever had a friend where there's
that one x that she cannot get over so
it doesn't matter who the next guy is
she's still thinking of that last guy
that's because that was the guy that she
felt like was the best that she could do
so as women i think we have an internal
like guard up against sleeping with
someone that's too high of a status
because we know if we sleep with them we
can't get over it
yeah i wouldn't sleep with you because i
just don't want to be one of many and i
don't think you're taking me seriously
i'm